This video is brought to you by Squarespace,
from websites and online stores to marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the one-on-one platform to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business.
You can check out Squarespace through the link in the description below.
I got more on them in a bit and let's get into it.
Andy Warhol was born three times. The first two,
his parents is Andy Warhol up the second time as a commercial artist,
raggedy Andy, after a failed fascination,
he was reborn the final time as the artistic Paragon and
cultural revolutionary, or then the worldwide as Andy Warhol, Charles,
number four to a poor immigrant family raised in a tenement building during the
great depression.
The story of ND is the story of the American dream itself with a
little extra obsession, drugs and murder sprinkled on top.
Perfect for his Hollywood heart.
It's impossible to overstate his contributions, not just a painting,
but to the entire science of seeing the idea that a mass market objects could be
elevated to the status of art. Just by how it's looked at.
It's such a profound rejection of every standard, which came before it,
that we no longer even recognize it as revolutionary.
It has been internalized whole cloth as the new truth.
The audience decides what is art?
Just as much as democracy is a rejection of the divine right of Kings Andy's
contributions to the American perspective is so ingrained that we no longer
recognize them as his art, his attention in the future.
We'll all be famous for 15 minutes.
The terms superstar is one he coins to describe the hippies and drag Queens that
are used for camera fought it.
And he understood better than any of his contemporaries.
That what the public wants is to be told that they matter that the trappings of
consumer culture are part of a grander narrative.
Even in television and movies, every behind the scenes feature pits,
heroic creatives against the evil studio money men,
it's not enough to enjoy a piece of entertainment.
The work itself must be the product of this Titanic struggle,
or it really doesn't have any weight to it. The drama gives it significance.
No one would remember five life.
It wasn't defined by the conflict between Joss Whedon at a bunch of nameless
executives who loved blowing huge opportunities. That's the drama,
which inspired Andy to paint Liza Minnelli as a career and marriage began
to crumble. That's why he painted his death and disaster series one,
which holds the record for Warhols most expensive work.
America loves an underdog and there is no bigger underdog than the victim in a
fight against yourself. It's a hunger for celebrities,
which drives their self destruction. And here Andy comes along,
turning a silkscreen headshot into the kind icon.
They build chapels around equal pods,
Relic and lecture on the cynical hazards of icon worship, the same hazard,
which would later temporarily customers' life.
And he grew up in the shadow of the Saint John Chris Austin,
Byzantine Catholic church,
which is known for its huge ends or need wall of gold leaf falling columns with
their unreasonably beatific expressions and similar poses.
This became the Genesis for Andy's experimentation with repeated images,
the worship for quality of his portrayed.
So the use of color elevates the mortal to the eternal. Everything is here.
You can trace every single one of his artistic motifs to this one place.
There's a direct line between spending eight hours a week in charge staring at a
gold leafed image of Marion's. Then 30 years later,
painting Marilyn Monroe on top of more gold leaf,
the conflation of consumption and worship is rampant in Warhols work because
that's is the language America uses to express desire and reverends.
They eat what they worship. Celebrity is communion.
Success in America is being incorporated into the greater whole,
like how the calcium in milk becomes bone and teeth.
Andy is the calcium of modernity. That's why his hair was white.
And the third grade,
he had to take a temporary leave of absence when a nerve disease named some
VITAS as dance, plagues him with involuntary muscle spasms,
he would struggle to write his name on the chalkboard and other children would
bully him so much that he simply refused to return.
It's this period of affliction and sickness in which the seeds of waterholes
genius sprout to keep him occupied.
His mother provided him with Hollywood magazines,
newsletters from fan groups and plenty of paper for experimentation going so far
as to build a doctrine in the basement for his photography will hold began
collecting autographed pictures with his Shirley temple.
As the jewel of the set to incentivize creation.
His mother would provide a piece of chocolate for every completed work of art.
This motivation clearly stuck with Anthony because after he recovered,
he continued taking art classes through elementary and high school,
pursuing a college degree at Carnegie Mellon in commercial art,
Amazing in 1948, Andy Warhola moved to New York city.
He was always withdrawn even before baking it a central part of his public
persona, a shy boy with a large nose and an inconsistent complexion,
which he would later attempt to address through surgery.
He was insecure about everything, but his talents,
the quickly attracted respect from the art directors and magazines for his
technical skills and the unique appeal.
If it's self developed blotted line technique or style of simple printmaking
using a wetting drawing pressed against transfer paper,
perhaps more so even than his art,
Andy developed a reputation for being well a bit weird.
In addition to his physical uniqueness, his clothes were tattered.
His shoes broken in and his art was delivered in crumpled paper bags rather than
professional portfolios.
In a phrase he kind of stuck out glamour was the first to commission him
to illustrate shoes for an article titled what is success perhaps accidentally?
He was credited as Warhol and his rebirth as a commercial artist when it was
complete.
His whimsical style soon won him contracts with Vogue Columbia records and
Tiffany and co is upwards trajectory. It's only increased when in 1952,
his mother arrived on the stupid as apartment to inform him that she had sold
the family house almost immediately.
They started collaborating on commercial works as well as art books for friends,
she designs and tan drew to record label for New York busker icon Moondog,
which even won an award,
no matter how much ends you may have worried about his mother embarrassing him
in front of his trendy friends.
They live together and work together for the next 20 years until her death as
hardworking as our son was how unique I and flowing script helped refine the
style that brought in so much praise and success. However,
this wasn't enough for the ambitious young artist, more than security.
He wanted to be respected for his talents. And even perhaps at Mott,
he wanted the world to know why he mattered
This flourishing point in his career.
The Tandy comes to grips with his same sex attraction,
even if fulfilling his ambitions brief difficult.
His first kiss didn't come until he was 25 and he wasn't able to perform the
rest of the night's duties after being rejected during a trip to Honolulu,
he complained to her friends that he had gone around the world with a boy and
his not even received one kiss,
most biographers contend to say that he was gay in an era where that could get
you arrested. But the truth is somewhat more convoluted.
The difficulty Walter had with relationships and the consummation there ROV as
well as his habit of incorporating voyeurism and celibacy into his creative
process has inspired much academic speculation as to as possible like sexuality.
He himself claims to be a Virgin in 1980.
This is contradicted by testimony from former lovers,
as well as the time that he sought treatment for an STD in 1960.
It's an extremely Andy Warhol move to saturate your life and work with sex
only to deny its ultimate power negating sex in an era where it had never been
more ubiquitous was just another way in which he stood out from the crowd and
observer of the culture that was chasing his every move.
[Inaudible].
Have you unfamiliar with new York's publishing scene in the 1950s,
Truman Capote was a young literary hot shot who was in the process of blowing
everyone's minds by somehow managing to succeed in writing strictly on
merit alone, instead of a college alumini network and someone else's money.
He was stylishly gay beloved by the art world and to Andy Warhol wanted to be
him. He started leaving little illustrations in capacity's mailbox.
It eventually escalated to Warhol waiting outside his door,
hoping to develop a friendship through sheer insistence.
It work Kaposi rejected him later describing him as one of those hopeless
people, you know,
nothing's ever going to happen to and a hopeless born loser,
a rejection like that can sure make a fellow appreciate being ghosted,
undaunted, or whole turned this rejection into fuel for his first fine art show.
15 drawings based on the works of Truman Capote,
despite being a master of all works of flowing unbroken lines,
none of them sold this,
set the pattern for his early forays into fine art on the rare occasions that he
actually managed to earn gallery space in the sharpest possible contrast to his
continued success as a commercial illustrator gallery owners and art dealers
refused to help him sell his work before he dismantled his obsolete,
there was a fairly substantial barrier between commercial and fine artists,
but even more so than that,
Andy was gay and is off putting in a city that eats weakness grounds had to gave
her the New York art scene sounds like the setup for a joke where the punchline
is Lucy came masturbating,
but this was absolutely the case in the 1950s.
Then the city was ruled by Jackson and his band of whiskey soaked
heterosexual abstract impressionists of what art dealers and buyers wanted.
When Warhol showed up with his second collection of ink drawings,
this collection was called studies for a boy book,
and there was simply no market for his kind of obsession.
It sort of scared people,
but no matter how good his work was everywhere Warhol went,
he was rejected for being too swish to camp, to weird those same traits,
which would soon bring him more fame and admirers than he could handle.
And look, maybe you're an aspiring artist or not. Well,
what have you been doing online?
Whether it's starting a business or something like that? Well,
that's where today's sponsors Squarespace can come in. Well, two simple things,
maybe you've got some idea for a website or a business,
or you want to show off your art. Well,
to the only way to find out if that's worth doing is to get that idea out into
the world.
And that can be a bit daunting because it's scary to go and pursue new things.
But you know, not knowing how to set up a website is not an excuse because,
well, you've got Squarespace.
Squarespace allows you to create a powerful website for whatever you're up to.
You want to sell something online? Yes. Set up a store with Squarespace.
Maybe you want to do a podcast. Oh yeah. Squarespace can do that. Hey,
it all starts on Squarespace with a beautiful template or you can start from
scratch or you can move over from an existing domain. But you know,
don't start from scratch. Just use one of the templates, no excuses.
And once you've gone through the super easy customization process,
there's no updates. There's no patches.
There's no tag of BS that you have to deal with.
Also Squarespace handles all the website. He staffer social integrations,
mailing lists. Yes,
it is all head to squarespace.com for a free trial.
And when you are ready to launch,
go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics to save 10% off your first
purchase of a website or a domain, and let's get back to it.
Uh, well.
Warhol is those widely known pop artist. He oddly invented the genre.
He was inspired most directly by the work of James Rosenquist and Roy
Lichtenstein, who both Rose to prominence painting,
flat representations of advertisements and other cultural detritus
Warhol set to work immediately.
Painting scenes taken from Nancy cartoons and comic book, wig advertisements.
The work was not popular even with Andy.
There's a period of approximately 14 months between Warhols decision to pursue
fine art and his first major success in 1961,
he painted two versions of a Coca-Cola bottle,
wonderful of the brush strokes and human marks of creation and the other without
Coca-Cola two was a sterile. And as hard-lined as a neon sign,
no trace of the artist remained nothing.
Human in short it's blew the first one out of the water,
his friends called it naked Savage barren,
nothing of the painting existed between the message and the audience,
no gradients. So shadows for the eye to Haydn. And he had found a star.
Wow.
Ariel Itau is the name of the woman who inspired Andy Warhol to paint the 32
cans of Campbell's soup. When he asked her for ideas, she simply said,
you like money. You should paint pictures of money. You should paint something.
Everybody sees every day that everyone recognizes like a can of soup
frenzy. Campbell soup was more than just the kind of convenient meal,
which didn't interrupt. His workflow is also held, deepen personal significance.
During his childhood,
his mother suffered from colon cancer and had to be hospitalized for six weeks.
Every day, she was gone.
His older brother would make him a soup and a sandwich and reassure him that his
mother was going to be okay. That's what these cans represents.
That's what that inspired by a sobbing child.
Desperate to believe that his mother will be okay taking their daily ritual of
soup consumption becomes reverends. And through his tie,
his mother was restored to him. We're not exaggerating.
When we said that Andy painted his religious icons to him. The soup can,
was a symbol of resurrection and it certainly resurrected his career while whole
painted one portrays of each available variety of Campbell soup.
And when they were displayed in a Hollywood gallery,
he bought the popup movements to the West coast instead of waiting for the world
to find out, to accept him. He batted down the doors instead.
[Inaudible].
August, 1962 marks another evolution in his career.
The incorporation of drawn and photographed silkscreens in his paintings.
The inconsistencies of his blotted lines replaced almost overnight with the
divine accidents of an artistic method reduced to assembly line efficiency.
He focuses first on Hollywood icons from his youth,
followed by stars in decline like Liza Minnelli.
And he got started on a series of Marilyn Monroe paintings.
The same day she died and eventually debuted them to huge public response using
a still from the 1953 movie,
Niagara bendy took an image of her in the prime of our youth and joy and fruit,
countless repeated silk screenings.
Eventually slowly transforms the joyful smile into a bit of grumpy mace,
the kind of richness grin, which precedes oblivion.
No peace makes this more clear than the Marilyn dipped here.
A series of colored portraits juxtapose next to a row of washed out and
incomplete black and white images. The commentary is obvious.
Not only does it resemble a film strip,
but the increasingly vague monochrome transfers really capture how it feels to
wear out the memory of a loved one. It's more than just death.
It's the very public death that only the extremely famous get to live through
the slow relegation to the B roll of history, perhaps not. Coincidentally,
this is also the era he starts producing and directing his own films.
Eight hours of the empire state building vanishing into the night sky,
six hours of his boyfriend sleeping,
the kind of deliberately impenetrable stuff that gets modern day freshmen kicked
out of film school. You also produce the campions unlicensed Batman Dracula,
which is exactly what you would imagine. Just two years later, Adam,
West's knowingly tongue-in-cheek take on the Cape Crusader debuts with the power
bap,
Batman TV and movie shows the parents remember though it was only ever displayed
in galleries or as part of shows,
these screenings were taking place in New York city and Hollywood at the height
of Warhols fame scenes,
a popular actor like Adam West would absolutely have access to the influence is
on the Knotel and remains a core part of Batman to this day.
Apparently even superheroes, when not beyond the reach of Warhol.
Why don't you just tell me your words.
In 1963 at a friend's a decorator's work and party space with
mirrors and tinfoil and the silver factory. It was born to Warhol,
silver represented both the coming space, age, future,
and the silver screens of Hollywood's glamorous past.
It also represented a mirror, narcissism and shorts.
It reflects now it gives us what we want us.
His entourage immediately starts using it as a base of operations for a nearly
continuous stream of artistic creation and revelry,
which would continue for most of the rest of the decade.
It became the de facto syndrome of the New York art scene.
Bob Dylan would go there. Jagger, Salvador Dali, Liza Minnelli,
William S Burroughs. Even David Bowie called himself a regular in one room.
People were doing speed and another people were filming a music video for the
velvet underground Warhol would be making silk screens in one corner of the
workshop while at the other drag Queens vamps.
It was in every sense back in alien.
And just like in the story of the Beckham's Warhol would find himself torn
asunder by the very party that he cultivated.
The central irony in the assassination of Andy Warhol is that he wasn't even the
initial target. He was the understudy for his own death.
Valerie Solanas stuffed the guns in a coat that day intending to murder her
publisher, Maurice Jared.
She waited outside his apartment for three hours in an unseasonably,
warm hat and coat,
but lucky for him missed that particular appointment with fate crestfallen,
but unwilling to abandon our plans for the day she had it next to Warhols
factory. He knew vinery is the author of an extremely graphic anti-male place.
So violence that he initially suspected her to be a police informant.
She believed him to be part of a conspiracy to steal this scripts.
When instead it had been misplaced. When they arrived in his office,
she drew her two automatic pistols and wounded Warhol.
She was preparing to execute an assistant when the elevator opened and she
simply fled Dunning herself over to the police. Several hours later,
she left behind a paper bag at the factory containing her address,
a backup gun and a single sanitary napkin.
The idea that the assassination of Andy Warhol was intended as some kind of
theatrical performance or social critique has been discussed quite seriously.
In academic circles. Battery's work is obscene and confrontational,
including the much maligned scum manifesto wins. The one woman organization,
it spawns the society for cutting up men shortly thereafter, many other artists,
including Chris burden in his museum, destroying sculpture, Samson,
which incorporates gun plans, their work for a certain type of new Yorker.
The temporary death of Warhol marks at the end of the innocent sixties,
the ramifications of the shooting would lingo with Warhol for the rest of his
days,
which is understandable considering he only survived because the doctor reached
into his chest and hands massage to his heart.
No one jumps back from that without a scar,
he was required to wear a surgical girdle around the operating sites,
much like these silver screen darlings.
He so admired and childhood far from being shocked out of a semi effected
malaise Warhol seem to retreat into the unreality of it all remarking before I
was shot,
I always thought that I was more half that than all that I always suspected.
The talk was watching TV instead of living life.
People sometimes say that the way things happen in movies is unreal,
but actually it's the way things happen in life. That's unreal.
The movies make emotions look so strong and real.
Whereas when things really do happen to you, it's like watching television.
You don't feel it right when I was being shot.
And ever since I knew that I was watching television, the channels switch,
but it's all television. While this brought down the Gates on the open door,
factory walls reputation as a nightclub, regular was just getting started.
He would spend so much of the seventies hobnobbing with New York royalty and the
theme of studio 54,
taking it all in as fuel for high paying commissions of celebrities, socialites,
and an actual shop. He founded his interview, a celebrity interview magazine,
which is still being published for a normal person.
That's a huge amount of work. Most people never even get to paint Azir,
let alone a full sharp, but for the creator of the exploding plastic,
inevitable, the orgy com art show, which inspired the rave.
It must've felt like he living retirement rather than spending the final decade
of his life. Resting on the laurels of the man who invented today.
Andy started collaborating with many young talents in the underground art scene.
His final gallery showing with data you're across the street from the nunnery,
which houses Leonardo da Vinci's last supper fittingly enough.
That last supper was the subject.
Massive something Warhold hold must have delighted in because he returned to
traditional brush painting. But the first time in 20 years,
he and a collaborator basket yard produced well over a hundred works,
including 10 punching bags,
which featured the face of Jesus painted across 10 punching bags will all still
holds the record for most works displayed on a single subject in February of
1987.
He died while recovering from what should have been routine gallbladder surgery,
the public wake shut down, large portions of New York and Pittsburgh,
where he was buried next to his parents of 58 years old for someone who had
lived through so much,
the depression world war two and assassination dying due to a moment's
accidental neglect feels anticlimactic unfinished like a silk screen
with two little paints. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do subscribe to this channel.
There is a link below smash that like button head on over and check out
Squarespace as well. There's a link below. Thank you for.
Okay.